et on en parle tout de suite avec
gilbert casasus il est professeur
ordinaire en études européennes
bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france donc je le disais
on est à un mois de la fin de la période
de transition post brésil des
négociations sont donc en cours pour
trouver un accord de libre échange entre
le royaume uni et l'union européenne
on voit que c'est compliqué encore une
fois est-ce que vous pensez que
réellement les deux camps peuvent
trouver un terrain d'entente dans ce
délai je n'exclus pas quand qu'en tout
dernier ressort qu caming dix mois une
seconde un accord puisse se réaliser
mais même là ce sera un accord a minima
c'est à dire que aujourd'hui l'union
européenne essaye de faire deux ou trois
petites concessions
le premier ministre irlandais a fait une
déclaration il se montre relativement
optimiste je suis en accord mais ce que
le chef de l'état français boon vient de
déclarer est évidemment totalement fondé
le problème
curieusement c'est aussi la france c'est
à dire comme la france parce que c'est
un pays limitrophes où vous disons
séparés par la mort de la grande
bretagne est particulièrement intéressé
d'avoir accès à la pêche dans les eaux
britanniques et c'est un casus belli
pour la france parce que la france veut
et comme on la comprend
défendre l'intérêt de ces pêcheurs alors
qu'il y ait des quotas de pêche de 12 à
18%
ça c'est la calculette qui va appeler
trouvé la solution miracle mais il ne
faut pas du tout sous-estimé ce conflit
qui oppose l'union européenne à la
grande bretagne notamment la france
alors on voit bien que le gouvernement
britannique aussi presse les entreprises
britanniques à se préparer aux
changements qui vont intervenir au 31
décembre cela signifie quoi concrètement
ce signifie que la grande bretagne a
joué à miser gros et a perdu et donc la
grande-bretagne maintenant près par les
entreprises à s'adapter à ce que
j'appelle une défaite politique c'est à
dire certains milieux conservateurs il
faut pas oublier que bronson et quand
même conservateurs avaient misé sur une
économie florissante en cas de brick
city lors le brut ils n'ont pas
d'économie florissante
donc maintenant c'est un tout petit peu
le champ de rattrapage
il faut voir maintenant ce qu'on peut
faire adaptez-vous trouvons les
meilleures solutions possibles les
mythes les dégâts c'est ça que cela veut
dire
l'ombre point le jeu d'hier elle a la
forme
l'arrogance même britannique 2009-2016
l'a complètement disparu parce
qu'aujourd'hui ce qu'on a promis n'est
pas arrivé à bon port c'est à dire avec
la pêche est justement s'il n'y a pas
d'accord ça veut dire que les relations
commerciales vont être entre l'union
européenne et le royaume uni vont être
régi par l'organisation mondiale du
commerce
quels en sont les effets seraient les
conséquences selon les règles du web
c'est pas c'est pal ou m6 qui va tout
déterminé il faut pas non plus voir là
une ambiance unité nationale qui
prendrait le dessus
non ça veut dire comme une autre pays
européen
c'est à dire que les règles normales ou
édictées par l'om c'est qu'ils sont des
règles internationales
on sait qu est un point c'est tout donc
votre plaire et dette relations sociales
entre l'union européenne et en bretagne
va être très comparable avec celle d'un
autre pays du continent américain où je
ne sais quoi encore ou asiatiques
donc il n'y aura pas d'exception
britannique
ce que vous voulez le morgan stanely
plexi terre c'était avoir tous les
avantages de l'union européenne et d'en
avoir au canard aucun inconvénient
évidemment ça prend électoralement mais
dans les fêtes ça ne correspond à pas
grand chose et peut-être aussi cela
devrait nous donner à réfléchir en
france notamment
ouais je sais un petit sourire en coin
tout ce qui rend 2016 2017
pendant la campagne électorale évoqué
ouvertement ou un peu moins ouvertement
le cas d'un freak si c'est à dire le
départ d'un produit on ne s'entend plus
du tout du tout pourquoi parce qu'ils
savent même présenté un brick fric si
pour la france ce serait mettre la peau
la france dans une position de faiblesse
énorme telle qu'elle est aujourd'hui
tel que c'est le cas aujourd'hui en
grande bretagne il faut pas faire de la
france une seconde compagne dans le
concert aux populations clients merci
beaucoup à vous à gilbert casasus pour
cet éclairage rappelle que vous êtes
professeur ordinaire en études
européennes